أعمق تعازينا لضحايا
هذا الزلزال المدمر في تركيا
في قلوبنا وعقولنا هناك مع
الشعب التركي علينا معالجة
هذا معًا وإظهار أنه معًا
ليسوا وحدهم في هذه الكارثة الطبيعية
[موسيقى]
حشدت الأجنبية أكثر من 10 أبحاث حضرية
وفرق الإنقاذ من عدد من
الدول الأعضاء وهي بلغاريا وكرواتيا وتشيكيا وفرنسا واليونان وهولندا وبولندا
ورومانيا لتقديم الدعم
الأول للمستجيبين على الأرض
بالإضافة إلى أن المجر وإيطاليا وإسبانيا
ومالطا وسلوفاكيا قد عرضت أيضًا
مساعدتهم
الخارجية.
إلى تركيا وسوريا
من الواضح أن الاتحاد الأوروبي كما رأيتم قد
أطلق آلية الحماية المدنية
وأعلن الرئيس الفرنسي للتو
أنه مستعد لإرسال بعض
الدعم إلى تركيا وسوريا للمساعدة